en el vídeo anterior vimos la fórmula
para curvatura y bueno recordando
supongamos tener una curva en un espacio
de dos dimensiones solo para hacerlo un
poco más sencillo
esta curva esta paramétrica da por una
función s de un número que corresponde a
un punto en la curva y después pensamos
en vectores tangentes unitarios como se
ven estos vectores tangentes unitarios
en cada punto de la curva así y también
vimos la curvatura misma que se denota
por la letra griega capa que simboliza
la razón de cambio de estos vectores
unitarios tangentes y no con respecto al
parámetro t sino con respecto a la
longitud de arco de ese y me refiero a
longitud de arco cuando yo tomo aquí un
pedazo de la curva longitud de arco se
refiere al tamaño de este pedazo de la
curva denotado por de ese y bueno tal
vez te pregunte si al tomar un pedazo de
la curva el vector tangente unitario en
ese pedazo cambia mucho de dirección o
cambia poco de dirección para ver eso
mejor puedes en otro espacio trazar cada
uno de estos vectores unitarios y los
coloca hasta el que todos inicien en un
mismo punto entonces bueno este vector
se ve algo así está apuntando este hacia
abajo este se mirará algo así este
apunta un poco más hacia abajo y se mira
así y bueno suponiendo que camina sobre
la curva vas tomando pequeños pasos de
tamaño de ese sobre la curva cuál será
la razón de cambio en el vector tangente
ese cambio será un vector y como la
curvatura es un valor lo que nos importa
es el tamaño de ese vector es decir el
valor del tamaño del vector tangente
mientras vas tomando pequeños pasos en
de ese ahora debemos pensar en dos cosas
primero
la función para el sector tangente
unitario y la noción de longitud de arco
voy a usar la s aquí y aquí en
parametrización de la curva porque están
relacionadas entonces bueno pondré un
ejemplo para que veamos qué quiere decir
esto entonces digamos que nuestra
parametrización con respecto a t es el
vector coseno de t en la componente x y
seno de t en la componente i y también
multipliquemos ambas componentes por una
constante r y esto significa que en el
plano coordenada x llevo ya dibujar aquí
un plano coordenada tenemos el plano
coordenada estamos aquí trazando un
círculo con radio r
ahora de manera más abstracta pongo aquí
otro ejemplo si tuviéramos ese dt igual
a cualquier función en general para la
componente xy para la componente y esta
es una versión más general que veremos
en paralelo al ejemplo que estoy
haciendo con coseno y seno de t entonces
bueno primero averiguamos cuál es este
vector unitario tangente es decir cuál
es la función que en todo punto nos da
un vector unitario tangente a la curva
para hacer eso debes darte cuenta que ya
tenemos más o menos una noción de lo que
debería ser el vector tangente la
derivada de nuestra función vector
evaluada como función de t la dirección
en la que apunta está en la dirección
tangente entonces si yo tomo su derivada
si vemos aquí s prima de t que es igual
a tomar la derivada de ambas de ambas
componentes la derivada de kosheh no es
menos seno de t multiplicada por r y la
derivada de sea no es coseno de t
multiplicada por r entonces bueno ahí
está la derivada de manera más abstracta
en este otro ejemplo tomamos la derivada
de cada una de las funciones en las
componentes entonces esto lo podemos
interpretar como el vector tangente
pero tal vez no sea un vector unitario y
queremos que sea un vector unitario
porque esto solamente nos está dando la
dirección en la que apunta y para que
sea unitario lo que vamos a hacer es
normalizar lo entonces lo normalizamos
para obtener una función del rector
unitario tangente al cual llamaremos t
mayúscula de t minúscula que puede
parecer un poco extraño pero bueno t
mayúscula está representada del vector
tangente d minúscula representa el
parámetro y esto sería igual a la
derivada de vector valuada pero vamos a
normalizar la entonces dividimos entre
su magnitud como función de t
así que vamos a sacar la norma de esto
entonces
la norma
del vector - seno
desde por r
jose no de té por r
esto es igual la norma de esto es igual
a la raíz cuadrada
de seno cuadrado
seno cuadrado de t por r al cuadrado más
coseno al cuadrado
dt por el real cuadrado y pues no
podemos factorizar a la r entonces
dentro del radical tenemos
seno cuadrado más coseno cuadrado y no
estoy escribiendo aquí las tres porque
bueno no importa por el momento ya que
ya que todo esto que está dentro del
radical es igual a 1 así que las tres no
importan aquí y por lo tanto todo esto
será igual a r lo cual significa que
nuestro vector unitario tangente será
igual a la función original pero
dividida entre r que resulta ser una
constante en este caso aunque no por lo
regular no es una constante entonces
dado que nuestra función original es
menos seno de t por r coseno de t por r
como lo estamos dividiendo entre r
la función que obtenemos es menos 0 dt
josé no dt y bueno en el próximo vídeo
seguimos con esto